how do you get better at small talk cuz
as an introvert it can be hard work I'm
going to talk about the three things
that you probably haven't heard of of
how to make small talk feel easy
effortless and kind of like all the
naturals do it small talk as an
introvert is one of the hardest things
to get over because it just sucks I want
to go deep I want to jump in I want to
skip the fourl but you can't not in this
Society there's a lot of people who need
something more and so I went on a little
bit of research to find out what is it
how do you actually get better at small
talk and I came up with these three
things that's what I'm going to share in
this video stick around for number three
I promise that one is the most important
one and it took me forever to learn it
because I thought only one and two
mattered but it's more than that so here
we go number one it's the belief that
anybody has common interest with you
it's the belief that there's always
something in common between you and
another person it doesn't matter how
different they are it doesn't matter who
they are there is always something in
common and your job is to be that blood
hound to get after the scent and find
that thing that you as human beings on
this spinning Rock have in common with
one another and reframing it as it's
always possible and there's always
something is much much better than man I
don't like this dude this dude's kind of
buming me out don't have anything in
common no you do but you have to find it
and that leads us to tip number two how
do you find it Well you got to find the
why behind the what so they like tennis
and you like reading maybe they're two
different things but there is a reason
that they like what they like and you
like what you like can you find the why
behind the what maybe they they they
like reading because it puts them in a
state of flow and the world can kind of
disappear for an hour which is exactly
why I love tennis because I can just get
on the court and just be in the zone and
for one hour Nothing Else Matters and
maybe that feeling of I just want to
escape for a little bit and be in my own
bubble hey maybe that's what we have in
common as introverts I don't know find
the why behind the what video games and
cooking are two different things but
maybe it's all about feeling immersed in
an activity you always have something in
common with somebody as long as you
start to find out why people do what
they do Simon s has that great Ted Talk
on this start with why but it doesn't
just apply to business and marketing
it's a basic human fundamental idea that
it's not about what we do it's about the
motivations the drives the things that
make us human what that leads to is
asking a lot of questions being curious
these are all great things and we know
this however we can fall into a trap
where all we do is ask questions be
curious get to know keep keep probing
keep asking and by the end of the night
you've learned so much about the other
person they haven't learned anything
about you does that sound familiar cuz
that's been my life
forever and it's frustrating because
what if somebody else isn't a great
question asker isn't curious about you I
I start to feel like man I put in all
that leg work come on let's let's make
it 50/50 but not everybody's like that
and that's why it's so important tip
number three own your
interests you got to deliver you got to
bring yourself to the conversation and
talk what you want to talk about that's
the hardest thing for me is to actually
say you know what that reminds me of a
book I'm reading and let me tell you
about it without asking without without
requesting permission I'm just going to
decide we're going to talk a little bit
about what I want to talk about and I'll
get some feelers out if you want to
enjoy speaking then you got to speak
about what you enjoy it's the only way
small talk for it to be really something
you like you got to like talking about
something you enjoy like it's got to
also fulfill you so talk about the video
games talk about the book you're reading
talk about what you saw on TV last night
bring up stuff you enjoy because you
never know other people might enjoy it
too and it might spark even more
interesting Direction so take that
confidence and own your own interest
don't just be curious about other people
that's what most introverts tend to do
also have the courage to assert yourself
and bring up some conversation topics of
your own that you want to talk about
those are the three tips and hopefully
your small talk will get better with the
a little bit of practice just remember
to own your interests cuz it's hard for
us introverts to do it but it's going to
pay off in the end thanks for watching
please subscribe I'll see you next time